hi everyone this is Professor M the
science and today I want to tell you
about the matrix formulation of quantum
mechanics also known as matrix mechanics
this is another one of our videos on
rigorous quantum mechanics the matrix
formulation of quantum mechanics was the
first consistent formulation of quantum
theory and it was first proposed by
Heisenberg Bourne and Jordan as early as
1925 it is equivalent to the later wave
mechanics formulation of Schrodinger and
are both unified in the state space
formalism so why do we care about matrix
mechanics the matrix formulation is most
useful when we deal with finite discrete
basis and the reason for that is because
then it reduces to the simple rules of
matrix multiplication in fact for most
practical solutions of quantum mechanics
we use the matrix formulation whether we
want to solve quantum mechanics on pen
and paper using analytical solutions or
we want to use the largest
supercomputers on earth to find
numerical solutions in this video I will
introduce how to write down Katz brass
and operators in the matrix formulation
of quantum mechanics and then I will
work through a number of examples to see
how the usual rules of matrix
multiplication can be used to calculate
quantum mechanical quantities so let's
go to introduce the matrix formulation
of quantum mechanics we start with cats
we expand the cat toy in a basis you
where the expansion coefficient C are
given by the bracket between you and
beside this C coefficient are what we
call the representation of the cat's eye
in the U basis and if you need a
refresher check out the video
representations to define the matrix
formulation of cats we arrange this
coefficient into a column vector and we
can do it either in terms of the
brackets europe's eye or directly in
terms of the expansion coefficient c
therefore in the matrix formulation of
quantum mechanics cats are written as
column vectors now that we know how to
write cats as column vectors we next one
to look at brows we expand the brows I
in the basis you in terms of the same
expansion coefficients see that we used
to expand the corresponding ket but in
this case the expansion coefficients are
the complex conjugates C star again if
you need to refresh it about this check
the video on representations that is
linked in the description to defy
the matrix formulation of brass we
arranged this coefficient into a row
vector we can again write this out in
terms of the brackets IU or in terms of
the complex conjugates of the C
coefficients therefore in the matrix
formulation of quantum mechanics bras
are written as row vectors after Keds
and brass the next quantity we need our
operators an operator a can be written
in the U basis as the sum over the outer
products of the basis States and the
expansion coefficients AI J are given by
the matrix elements of a with respect to
the basis States
the very name matrix element for this
quantity comes from the matrix
formulation of quantum mechanics that we
will see in a moment the expansion
coefficients for an operator are labeled
by two indices so what we will do is to
arrange them in the form of a square
matrix with the first index denoting the
row of the matrix and the second index
the column of the matrix therefore in
the matrix formulation of quantum
mechanics operators are written as
matrices as a summary in the matrix
formulation of quantum mechanics a ket
sy which is expanded in terms of the C
coefficient in the U basis is written as
a column vector of these C coefficients
abrupt sigh expanded in terms of the
sister coefficient is written as a row
vector and an operator a expanded in
terms of the matrix elements a IJ is
written as a matrix at this point you
will all be thinking okay we can arrange
the representations of ket's
bras and operators as vectors and
matrices but what is the point of all
this and here is the point of matrix
mechanics when we write States and
operators as vectors and matrices then
all the manipulations of these objects
that we need to perform in quantum
mechanics can be performed in terms of
the usual rules of matrix multiplication
in the rest of the video I will look at
the four operations listed here to see
what they look like in the matrix
formulation of quantum mechanics some of
these expressions give scalars some give
cats and some give operators so we will
see how all this fits together in the
language of matrix multiplication let's
start with the bracket sci fi which we
now give the scalar we first write both
sigh and Phi in the Yuba
and we do this in terms of expansion
coefficient c and v calculating the
bracket between Si and Phi we first
write down the expansion of both these
terms in the U basis by copying the
expansions we wrote on the Left we can
then rearrange this expression in the
usual manner and we obtain this double
sum over I and J as the basis is also
normal we recognize this bracket as
Delta IJ so the double sum becomes sum
over i CI star di this last expression
here is the expression for the scalar
product of a row and the column vector
to see this explicitly we write the
props I as a row vector of sistar
coefficients and we write the cat file
as a column vector of D coefficients
using the usual rules of matrix
multiplication we first get c1 star
times d1 we then add C to star times d2
and so on and combining this term into a
sum we obtain this comparing this term
with this term we see that indeed they
are the same therefore a bracket in the
matrix formulation of quantum mechanics
is the matrix product of a row vector
with a column vector next let's look at
the action of an operator a on a cat
side giving us another cat side Prime we
start in the same way by first writing
both sigh Prime and sigh in the U basis
and in this case the corresponding
expansion coefficients are C Prime and C
the cat side prime is represented by the
C prime coefficient and the cat SCI is
represented by the sequel officiants
therefore to describe the action of the
a operator we need to find what the C
prime coefficients are in terms of the
seeker officiants to do that we first
write CI prime equals the bracket
between UI and beside prime we then use
the definition of Sai Prime in terms of
a to write this we then insert the
identity operator after a with an insert
the resolution of the identity in the U
basis as shown here and we then
rearrange to obtain a sum over J of
these two terms the first term is the
matrix element a IJ and the second term
is CJ so we can write the whole thing
sum over J a
jcj this last expression here is the
expression for the action of a matrix on
a column vector to see this explicitly
we first write down the matrix a we then
write down the column vector C and then
we use the usual rules of matrix
multiplication so we start with the
first row of the matrix acting on the
column vector to obtain the first entry
here and we can then continue with the
subsequent rows of the matrix obtain the
subsequent entries here each of the rows
corresponds to one of these sums here so
we can collect all the rows into the
column vector for C Prime as expected
multiplying a matrix with a column
vector gives us another column vector
just as the action of an operator on a
ket gives us another ket the next
example I want to look at is the adjoint
operator which describes the action of
an operator in the dual space we start
with the matrix element IJ of the
adjoint of a this is equal to the matrix
element of a dagger with respect to UI
and UJ we can then use conjugation to
write this as UJ a UI star and this
simplifies to complex conjugate of the
matrix element ji of a what this is
showing is that we need to exchange IJ
by ji and then take the complex
conjugate therefore in order to go from
the operator a to the adjoint operator a
dagger we first write the operator a in
matrix form as shown here and we then
transform it into the adjoint operator
by exchanging rows with columns and then
taking the complex conjugate of each
entry therefore the matrix formulation
of the adjoint of an operator a is given
by the transpose conjugate matrix of the
original operator the final example I
want to look at is how we write an
operator as now the product of two
states we again start by writing Tsai
and Phi in the U basis in terms of the
expansion coefficients C and D we then
build the outer product sci fi and then
insert the expansion of these two state
in the U basis as shown here rearranging
this expression as usual we obtain a
double sum over I and J for some
coefficients C ID J star and then the
outer product of the basis States
comparing this to the usual expression
for an opera
in a particular basis we identified the
CID J star term as the matrix elements
of this operator since it is explicitly
in the matrix formulation we write the
cat psy as the column vector of C and
multiply by the broth I as the row
vector of D using the standard rules of
matrix multiplication we first combine
c1 with D 1 star to get the first entry
here then c1 again with D 2 star to get
the second entry and so on to fill the
first row we can then repeat all these
multiplications but now with the c2
rather than c1 so we obtain the second
row here and so on and that expected the
result is a matrix whose entries are
precisely the matrix elements of the
operator up here the outer product is
therefore given by the matrix
multiplication of a column vector with a
row vector and the result is a matrix
overall we have looked at four examples
to show that the usual rules of matrix
multiplication allow us to do the usual
operations of quantum mechanics in the
matrix formulation of this theory a
bracket is written as a row vector times
the column vector which leaves a scalar
the action of an operator a on a ket sy
is written as the multiplication of a
matrix by a column vector which gives
another column vector the adjoint
operator is written as the transpose
conjugate matrix and the outer product
of two state is written as the
multiplication of column vector with row
vector which gives a matrix you can play
with these and similar expressions
yourself and here I have two more you
should show that the first one gives a
scalar and the second one gives a matrix
so what have we learned today we have
introduced the formulation of quantum
mechanics known as matrix mechanics this
is the most useful formulation for the
practitioner of quantum mechanics
because it reduces all operations to
matrix multiplications if you liked this
video or you would like to send me
suggestions for future videos please
subscribe